we dated for five six years how did you  propose to her so I got us a trip to  Martha's Vineyard nice I've never been  it's nice it's great beautiful time this  year was the summer and uh we got on a  moped ride and we saw the whole island  and we pulled over and I said I got to  take a whiz I start peeing and I go can  you keep a look out she's staring at the  ocean I'm peeing in the woods and  there's two old people on the on the  beach just holding hands you know  watching the ocean and I'm peeing and  I'm getting the [ __ ] ready while she's  looking out for me and I go oh I snipped  it all right I zipped it up can you help  me and she turned around and I was on  one knee ah and then she went nut  started crying and the old couple at the  beach went yeah that a baby or whatever  so it was kind of a fun moment